boa tarde
[Música]
é
é é
é né
[Música]
i
o amor é fogo que arde sem se ver é
ferida que dói não se sente é um
contentamento descontente a dor de
desatina 'single' ou não querer mas que
bem querer andar solitário
a gente nunca contentar-se de contente
não cuidar que ganha e se perder e que
deveria estar preso por vontade servir a
quem vence o vencedor é ter com quem nos
mata lealdade mas como causar pode seu
favor nos corações humanos amizade se
tão contrário assim mesmo
o amor sempre me julguei vale em fosse
quem fosse o meu enfrentava
debaixo do sol quente sobre essa terra
não tem um que me ganha a respeitado em
toda redondeza
sem conhecer as alegrias na paixão feliz
em mim e desavisado envia apaixonado
assim de supetão e na primeira vez que a
vi nem me mexi foi se a coragem que
comichão é esse que me tirou um tempo me
faz viver essas miragens mulher porque
tu faz assunto não tem dó de mim ache
que fosse linda isso de amor mulher
achei que fosse história
esse troço m aperto pt dá cá ou mulher
porque assim não tem dó de mim achei que
fosse linda isso de amor à mulher
achei que fosse história esse troço que
me aperto pp e da calor
ae é aí
ah ah ah ah ah ah eu sempre me julguei
valente fosse quem fosse o meu
enfrentava debaixo do sol quente sobre
essa terra não tem um time ganhava
respeitado em todo o mundo nerd sem
conhecer as alegrias na paz
desavisado e apaixonado assim de supetão
da primeira vez que a mim e me mexi
fosse a coragem que comichão é esse que
me tiro como me faz viver essas miragens
mulher porque faz assim tu não tem dó de
mim achei que fosse emenda isso de amor
à mulher
achei que fosse história e se posso
tinha perto pt da gaúcha
a mulher porque tu faz assunto não tem
dó de manhã achei que fosse venda isso
de amor
achei que toda história e se posso m
aperto já acabou
[Música]
é a
a que era ai ai
a valeu
[Música]
ela te dão gente essa música se chama
lenda é uma música minha e vou tocar
mais uma composição minha aqui pra vocês
se chama a folha esse som fala de ciclos
eu não gosto de explicar muito porque eu
acho que é bacana que cada um de vocês
recebam a música da maneira que quiser
que ela faça sentido para vocês da
maneira que for melhor porque às vezes a
gente explica muito parece que se eu
disser alguma coisa né que não foi que
vocês pensaram parece que a música perde
a validade ea idéia não é essa
só porque a música é minha não significa
que ela também não pode ser de cada um
de vocês
da maneira que vocês acharem melhor hora
[Música]
olha a folha de coca caiu olhe
esse o destino da fogo é esse aí
onde será que leva cada lento que sobra
fui até cair a cada queda nova plantação
legados lembranças de uma outra sensação
de tarde
e é tarde
mas olha menino pra corrido bem ali
corre cai levanta não
e você acha que é seguro e faz do seu
seguro seguro para alguém seguir cada
traço passo face lembrança só o
continuação que cresce e floresce
perecem noy virá mais pra ser refrão e
olha pra onde você deseja aí seja o que
desejar ser o tempo se esvai sem pedir
sim concedeu olhar de quem um dia céu
vai sé se assim mesmo permite
indo ter esse e da folha cair e olha a
folha tá caindo ali e seu destino da
folha é mesmo esse aí
onde será que leva cada lento que sobra
folha até cair a cada quinta nova
plantação regados lembranças de uma
outra sensação de tarde
é tarde
[Música]
a folha da casa